hey guys it's alexis i know a lot of
people are at home right now and you're
wondering what they can make from their
fridge and their pantry i'm here to help
there's so many great options that you
probably have at home that you don't
even know about today i'm gonna help my
friend destiny use what she has at home
to make a great unexpected meal let's
get started
[Music]
hi destiny how are you doing i'm really
excited about what we're going to make
today
me too i have a bunch of random things
and i really wanted to see like what i
could make now that we're kind of have a
lot more time on our hands that are at
home i'm like really interested in
learning new recipes to kind of add to
my shuffle can you walk me through your
kitchen and show me what you've got yeah
for sure let's start with my fridge
perfect
so we've got some tofu back there is
some veggie broth got lots of pickle
oh i have some pepperoni yum i've got
some asparagus
some cilantro an onion
awesome and here we've got some green
beans
and some lettuce and then i have sauces
and dressing ginger sriracha of course
we've got some hoisin sauce okay i've
got a lot of frozen fruit wait is that
frozen sorry frozen avocado is that a
thing yeah it's for smoothies some
frozen corn we've got broccoli and then
also some frozen asparagus that i forgot
about and brown rice wow i have a lot of
stuff oh my god you are set and my
pantry quote-unquote i have a lot of
noodles so we have some rice noodles
i've got some spaghetti some penne pasta
we've got black beans that's kind of
like the bulk of my pantry and what i've
got going on cool i'm guessing you have
olive oil i do okay great start and then
do you also have garlic oh i think so
let me check because i suck at like
cutting garlic i have like this stuff do
you have anything like coconut milk oh
wait i think i do got some coconut milk
amazing okay awesome great and do you
have curry cakes by any chance i don't
have curry paste but i do have these
like
curry cubes that like melts into the
dish that would totally work
this is like all such random food that
i've had forever you have so much food
this is amazing i feel like there's so
many different directions we could go we
can make a tofu curry with a bunch of
vegetables and serve it over those rice
noodles we can make a veggie fried rice
we could also do something like a really
simple pasta i feel like the vegetables
are going to be the real stars here oh
god now i need to think i love pasta and
that's such a staple so i think it'd be
really fun to try to make like a fun
veggie pasta totally
[Music]
okay destiny i've got your list ready
for you for this recipe you're gonna
need pasta
olive oil
onion
garlic
pesto fresh asparagus fresh green beans
frozen broccoli
veggie broth and of course salt and
pepper
okay it looks like you have everything
you need so let's get cooking let's do
it
a few things are gonna happen at the
same time but we're gonna go
step-by-step bring a large pot of water
to a boil and we're also going to add
like a few good pinches of salt to the
pot oh okay so salting your pasta water
is just going to flavor the noodles keep
going oh way more oh way more okay way
more that's good so the next thing
you're gonna do is get another pot and
add the veggie broth to it so we're
actually gonna cook the vegetables in
the veggie broth again just to add more
flavor awesome pot number two do you
think the spaghetti will fit in the pot
that it's in right now you know i have
that same thought i think i might swap
the perfect
i love it so now you can add the veggie
broth to the small pot how much broth
should i add you want to leave like
at least an inch at the top you know
hopefully it can be the whole thing
perfect i feel like i'm there
yay i love that you can also set that
pan over medium-high heat maybe like
yeah that's perfect and again we're
gonna add some salt to the veggie broth
so much salt i know but it's really like
infusing the vegetables with flavor well
that's great i mean i love flavor so i'm
not mad that's good so the next thing
we're gonna do is trim the green beans
and then chopping them into like two
inch pieces i suck at chopping things so
i'm gonna need you to walk me through
totally
[Music]
show me okay so just like snap off
just that little end part can you see my
cutting i cannot but i can hear it
no no no it's so tiny at like in the
little corner of my phone i can't see it
okay so cut the ends off can you hold a
bean up to me okay let's cut them into
like maybe just halves instead of
cutting it straight like this we're
gonna just cut it like on a diagonal
does that make sense i think so just
like just uh
looks like a that feels like a tick-tock
dance
oh yeah you got it
it's such an easy little thing to just
like make it a tiny bit prettier i like
that i want to start cutting on the
diagonal more often green beans done yes
green beans oh sorry that's my face i
wanted to show you and you can grab that
bunch of asparagus so the ends of it are
like these
woody
tough ends that you don't want to eat so
move one asparagus out towards the
bottom and then just snap it oh just
snap it so it's a really good trick to
know like where to trim it that's such a
good tip i usually just guess make that
same bias cut on the asparagus
like that beautiful look at that
i'm a chef you're a chef
is the water boiling and is the veggie
broth boiling yes actually so first put
the pasta into the pot of boiling water
should i use the whole box half a box
let's use half a box question
spaghetti or penne does it matter what
kind of pasta i mean it doesn't really
matter but i think for this let's use
spaghetti okay wow i'm like struggling
how do you use a phone someone show me
can you see okay is that half
it's a little less let me grab some more
no no no i think that looks perfect okay
perfect can i put the cooking time on
the box 10 minutes 10 minutes perfect so
set your timer for 10 minutes
as soon as that pasta cooks down a bit
we can shove the rest in okay now to the
veggie broth i hope this all fits in
there you're gonna add the green beans
okay and asparagus to the veggie broth
oh boy okay let's try so far so good and
then also about a cup of the frozen
broccoli okay
oh uh
we uh got some freezer burn you know
what we're pivoting pivot oh
destiny push that pasta down into the
water yeah nice and then the vegetable
set a timer
for
two minutes on your stove i've also
never done that before wow all these
things
two minutes i'm not sure if i'm doing my
time or changing the time on my stove
you know what i'm going to keep track on
my clock here but you can get a coffee
and put it in the sink okay perfect got
the collagen you already got a colander
okay i want the vegetables to still be
bright and crunchy but cooked cooking
time we're gonna see about it might need
another minute can you take a piece of
asparagus out and
just bite it to see how tender
sure i can do that
got one
does it feel like it needs to be cooked
longer i'd say maybe another minute or
two like another minute yeah okay cool
uh you can just put that back in the pot
since it's just used it's just me
[Music]
while we give this another minute you
can trim the ends off the onion i will
say disclaimer this is an onion i've
used previously so it's all right that's
fine oh my god half an onion this is the
ultimate pantry pasta so set the onion
on the flat side down
flat side down yep that's going to help
it secure to the cutting board and be
way safer when you're cutting it awesome
you're going to trim off that nubby end
that's a perfect spot to cut it
and then turn it around
and trim that side off too
and now just peel the outer layer off
perfect
okay actually now we're going back to
the vegetables oh what are we going to
do with them we're going to drain the
vegetables in the colander in the sink
got it i like that i'm saying we as if
i'm there you are you're basically here
okay so these bad boys
run your cold water over the vegetables
and this is just gonna stop them from
cooking
and just like
uh you know make sure yeah yeah
and how much time is on for the pasta i
have two minutes left okay perfect
actually give the pasta a stir just to
make sure the noodles aren't sticking
together oh awesome back to the onion
back to the onion i'm just gonna have
you thinly slice the onion so
hold
one of the ends that you trimmed off
like this like this grip it down on the
other side and then start slicing yeah
exactly
and just watch your hands i feel so
chef-like
you are also any tips for not cutting my
fingers off yes you really want to make
it claw over your fingers i would say
stop chopping you can save that onion
for later and how much time is left on
the pasta it is now time okay before you
drain it do you have like a glass
measuring cup i do not i only have like
the scoop that's fine so take one of
those okay like about a half cup okay
and fill it with uh the pasta water ooh
i see this a lot i've never done it
first time for everything you're gonna
just leave that off to the side the
chefs call it like liquid gold because
it helps pasta sauces come together
makes them smoother makes the sauce
cling to the noodles according to the
noodles and now you can drain the pasta
i'm gonna take you with me
actually i can't because it's a big pot
okay okay beautiful so just give that a
shake and put it back in the pot okay
i'm like
dripping
that's okay and then give a good glug of
olive oil i'll tell you when how about
okay
a little more yep and now
and then just toss it it'll help them
not stick together
yeah nice
[Music]
okay we're almost done bear with me
do you have a large pan like a large
frying pan wait like how big like big or
like big big um big like you could cook
two eggs in it oh yeah okay so now adds
like about a tablespoon of oil
to that you don't have to measure it out
i can just tell you tell me when to stop
keep going
good and set the pan over medium-high
heat one trick to tell when the oil is
hot is when the oil starts to shimmer on
the top it'll probably take about a
minute you can't too it's hard to tell
on a tiny tiny screen when you put your
hand to like right over it without
touching it obviously how does it feel
pretty warm pretty warm okay you can add
the onions to the pan this is a lot of
onion it's gonna cook down
that sound that sound we're not to like
fully caramelize these onions but i just
want to cook them down a bit so that
they get that kind of sweet umami flavor
interesting they smell good see how
they're like beginning to get kind of
golden brown yeah we want them all to be
golden brown oh all right and then you
can stop stirring for a minute i always
tell my boyfriend this he loves to like
stir things obsessively and i'm like you
gotta let it cook yeah i'm the same i'd
love to just like
it's like it's soothing right i'm sorry
it's okay
let me see the onions now we're getting
a little crispy okay now give them a
stir and we're still gonna let them go a
bit longer just trust me i mean you're
the chef i do trust you
okay i also know that you think this is
a lot of salt but just add like a
sprinkle of salt on the onions you're
trying to have my blood pressure just
flavor and then what you can do well let
those onions go is get a little spoon
for the garlic my kitchen is a mess oh
my god it's a tasty cookbook oh yeah i
love it so you're gonna fill up like
half the spoon with garlic okay
um
a little less than that
yeah perfect add them to the onions and
give it a stir
nice
that's the sound that's the sound oh it
smells so good when you're cooking
garlic you basically want to cook it for
like a minute just until it becomes like
really aromatic if you go longer than
that the garlic will burn and like you
know burnt garlic isn't like the flavor
we're after here no we're not going for
that
[Music]
so what we're gonna do now is going to
add that onion garlic mixture to the
pasta
nice and now we're going to add all
these vegetables in
you're going to get that pesto and a
spoon i'm sorry i got to put you down so
i can open it
i've got my pesto your pesto i'm gonna
say you want to add about a quarter of
the container and let me see how much
that is get some dollops
beautiful okay
now you're gonna take some of that pasta
water and add just a tiny a little bit a
little bit of pasta yup just like a
splash a splash
another splash okay
and now toss everything together you can
see how it's helping the pesto really
like spread out yeah that's great i feel
like with pesto or thicker sauces
sometimes it doesn't always spread
evenly
and i would add just like
i would add a little more salt i mean
you can taste it i would add some like
salt and pepper to taste love it and
then just toss it again to make sure the
salt and pepper goes all over destiny
you're done you made lunch yay
yay this looks so good i'm so excited to
try this moment of truth i can't wait to
hear what you think i hope you like it
i'm really excited it's like really
pretty i've got a big old fork full he's
my eating face
so good oh my god i'm so jealous okay
let me stop eating it's literally so
good
i'm so glad thank you so much like i'm
probably gonna add this to my rotation
now because it was so easy to make it
was my pleasure i mean this was so fun i
just want to help people make great food
well thank you
that was so fun i'm a bit jealous of
destiny's lunch but i'm so happy i got
to help her inspire her and teach her a
few new things about cooking i'd love to
know what you're making at home and if
you have been cooking alongside your
friends and family using you know all
our technology and how you're getting
creative
[Music]
you